we'll just wait and bide our time they
didn't get a chance buccaneers did
buccaneers took kyle trask
at the end of round two
starting this second tier run on
quarterbacks because then it went trask
monde and davis mills to the texans but
they could have taken any quarterback
they wanted with the final pick in round
two
they like trask chris why do you think
they like trash more than mine well i
think you know we heard a little clip of
like uh of bruce arians you know in one
of our little pft or peacock peapods or
whatever they're like you know i think
the size hey played a lot of football at
florida you know and got a good little
field knows how to play the game at the
position
to me you know again what i want to say
is you know mike you're asking me what
what do they see i'm going i don't know
quite all the way it's a slow release
it's not a real strong arm it's a below
average athlete for this age in the nfl
and he doesn't necessarily play really
big to me that's where i was a little
surprised by it that way um but hey they
saw otherwise so we'll see where they go
it is a great situation too you know if
they can adjust keep him in shape and
quick like he was at his pro day and
adjust his throwing a little bit maybe
they see an avenue to marry or maybe he
they think he's better than what i
envisioned uh but yeah i was i was
intrigued that they went with him first
i really was
and uh buccaneers fans if it doesn't
work out at least they tried and
they didn't take a kicker with a second
round pick you have that going forward
right which is nice they actually
were thinking about taking him
up at the end of round one right i heard
yeah so uh yeah so they they know that
they need someone to develop
beyond tom brady because brady's got
i think you can count on two more years
from britain we can count on one yeah
count on one maybe two presume two
uh and then
maybe just maybe you get three but the
the reason you even though he intends to
stay at least two more years father time
eventually is gonna win and we've seen
nothing to suggest that father time is
in the process of winning but when it
happens
it's going to happen quickly i think and
we're always watching for it any bad
game oh oh is is it starting is it
starting and then he comes back and he
looks as good as ever but
that's what they have to be ready for
the possibility that father time shows
up and kicks tom brady's butt at some
point during the 2021 season that really
is the only
i mean if i'm a buccaneers fan and i'm
looking for things to worry about that's
the only thing i'm worried about i mean
everyone's back super bowl championship
team first time since the 70s that you
got all your starters the only thing i'm
worried about is tom brady well uh all
of a sudden losing it and then who's my
backup you know
you got a big drop off well you know the
bucks got anti-aging cream you know that
that's what they got
you know it it it is slipping to a
degree we're just not going to quite
quite see it it's an awesome offensive
line it's great weapons it's a great
defense
so it's not going to always be on them
and it's a great formula for a guy
that's his age to then go like it gets
into a little bit like what you were
kind of saying with kirk yeah brady's
not going to make plays off schedule
anymore and he's not great when the
pocket's collapsing are people around
him but doesn't matter tampa's built a
damn team where that's that's few and
far between and as long as he feels like
oh i'm clean and protected we can see he
could still throw that pill all over the
field at a really high level and that's
where it's it's amazing to watch it
really is his arm is just special still
i'm surprised you're not all in with
kyle trask for one very important reason
you can wear the deuce you mean that
white reason we're in the deuce i know
putting the deuce on it how dare they
unretire my number two this is a problem
league wide what's going on here
[Laughter]
oh that's right it's not retired that's
right do you give your blessing do you
give your blessing
the deuce as an underwhelming starting
quarterback for the buccaneers and once
a third rounder and now a second rounder
i give you the number two jersey
congratulations kyle trask hang on to
your spleen baby yeah you're going to be
playing at some point
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports